ce soir vous nous parlez d'une
association la courte échelle cette
association lutte contre le décrochage
universitaire pour les étudiants en
droit oui Mathilde et cette association
elle est d'ailleurs récente elle a été
créée l'année dernière par Youssef bad
qui est le premier vice-président
adjoint au tribunal judiciaire de
Bobigny et c'est association est là pour
objectif de mettre en relation des
professionnels du droit avec des
étudiants alors ça fonctionne grâce un
système de parrainage pour que
l'étudiant puisse bénéficier de soutien
et de conseils pendant sa scolarité et
le deuxième objectif de l'association
c'est aussi d'aider ces derniers à
trouver des stages et dans les Yvelines
notamment une convention a été signée
avec la cour d'appel de Versailles qui
s'engage désormais à accueillir 1 à deux
étudiants chaque année alors comment
faire pour être aidé par cette
association alors il y a pas vraiment de
pré-requis pour entrer dans cette
association par contre il faut tout de
même être à partir de la deuxième année
d'études de droit il n'y a pas non plus
d'exigence sur l'école donc l'étudiant
peut tout aussi bien être issue d'un IUT
ou d'une fac par exemple et puis pour
boucler la boucle j'ai envie de dire pas
de limitation géographique non plus
puisque l'association reçoit des
demandes de partout en France
métropolitaine mais aussi des
départements et des régions d'outre-mer
alors ce qui est aussi intéressant c'est
cette volonté de Youssef bad qui est
d'aider les étudiants c'est un peu
finalement comme un exutoire pour lui
puisqu'il a rencontré énormément de
difficultés pour aller au bout de ses
études et vous êtes justement parti à sa
rencontre Régine je vous propose de
l'écouter si moi je le faisais pas si
vous voulez c'était c'était quasiment
anormal en fait pour deux raisons la
première c'est que je suis passé à un
cheveu de l'abandon universitaire en
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle la L3 à
l'époque ça plaît la licence j'ai
abandonné mes études pendant deux ans
parce que j'ai dû travailler à côté et
ça n'est que par l'intervention d'un
professeur que j'avais eu tout au début
et qui
connaissait mes compétences en tout cas
de ce qui me disait et qui m'a mobilisé
avec certains membres de ma famille pour
reprendre mes études sans ça je l'aurais
jamais fait et je le regretterai
aujourd'hui sûrement amèrement et la
deuxième c'est un constat très simple
c'est que je n'ai jamais décroché le
moindre stage lorsque j'étais étudiant
j'ai envoyé des centaines de CV je n'ai
jamais obtenu une seule réponse je pense
qu'il y a plusieurs raisons à ça mais
aujourd'hui moi je me suis dit je suis
arrivé je suis magistrat si moi je fais
pas ça qui est le fera en fait
et donc comme on a pu l'entendre les
difficultés sont bien présentes dans
cette filière et d'ailleurs si on
s'attarde sur les chiffres du ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur en première
année de licence c'est plus de la moitié
des élèves qui échouent aux examens 54%
pour être plus précis sur l'année 2020
2021 ce sont des chiffres conséquents
effectivement régime et est-ce que vous
avez pu échanger du coup avec des
bénéficiaires de cette association oui
Mathilde j'ai rencontré si deria Dramé
donc elle est en stage à la cour d'appel
de Versailles j'ai également rencontré
Robin muratiol qui est chef de cabinet
et qui est en contact direct avec
l'association la courte échelle je vous
propose de les écouter je trouve que
c'est ma réelle opportunité et je trouve
ça vraiment incroyable qui est tout ce
dispositif autour pour pour vraiment
aider des
étudiants en droit à trouver des stages
parce que c'est nécessaire à notre
formation c'est assez difficile parce
que c'est soit on doit passer par notre
réseau personnel
pour la plupart des étudiants ils l'ont
pas ou on doit déposer les candidatures
mais le souci avec ma formation c'est
que ces formations qui
n'est pas très connu du milieu juridique
de ce fait
entre guillemets on va dire qu'il y a
des élèves de licence sont beaucoup plus
les élèves issus de licence sont
beaucoup plus
facilement recrutés on est très content
de notre expérience et on souhaite
absolument la renouveler et c'est vrai
que
j'allais dire dans le droit on a bien
sûr les étudiants des filières
universitaires un peu classiques mais
aussi des filières plus
professionnalisant comme comme les IUT
et là encore eux aussi pour nous c'est
un enrichissement parce que c'était de
ces étudiants qu'on accueillait pas
parce que ça se présentait pas on
accueillait pas ces étudiants avant et
là encore une fois depuis l'année
dernière on est très contents ça nous
fait aussi une ouverture pour nous et
encore une fois on est aussi très
sensibilisé au volley dimension sociale
ascenseur social pour être plus précis
voilà alors l'association est très
active aujourd'hui en un an c'est plus
de 2000 demandes de stage qui sont
traitées et plus de 270 parrainages
partout en France merci beaucoup Régine
ralege pour toutes ces informations et
si vous êtes intéressé vous trouverez
plus d'informations sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran